what's going on boy i'm already know the
[ __ ] vibes checking me out on bootleg
chaos podcast bootleg cab [ __ ]
yo boulet kev show we got a special
guest here
moray yeah yeah yeah hey man look i was
in the studio with you a few months ago
and i told you something i don't know if
you remember but i was like i think i
heard maybe 10 or 15 songs
and uh yeah i was like i don't know if
it's possible and there's a few artists
that i could say this for
because all the songs i heard were fire
but but there's certain artists
that i think it'd be really hard for
them to make a bad song
yeah and i told you i was like yo i feel
like you're the kind of guy where i
don't know if i'll hear a shitty song
from you
hey you hey you've even
known for real i really hope that's a
goddamn case i'm gonna try my best to
make sure it is no cow
yeah man so um street sermons is coming
out friday right
tomorrow tomorrow yeah so tomorrow night
28th man my first mixtape ever i'm
[ __ ] excited [ __ ] yeah i'm also
nervous
you're nervous why are you nervous i i
really want to because i
i want people to understand that i
really gave my all so i don't want
people like oh this [ __ ] took too long
and gave us some regular [ __ ] like i
really want people to love this [ __ ]
like
it's it's really big to me that my fans
like this
like this project because i i put myself
in this [ __ ]
right and that's my first time ever
telling [ __ ] about my story or who i
am so i'm
you feel me it's like hot damn i'm gonna
take my clothes off you really see the
body
like it's crazy bro right right so when
you say you tell your story like what
was your most vulnerable
moment on this project like something
you talked about that you know
like uh i believe like uh was the song
reflections
when i was talking about like how i
[ __ ] up and learned some lessons i had
my mom stressing
like how i was locked up and how i had
to get my ged because i was
i was locked up and how i was able to
finish school the way i wanted to and
then mistakes and saying like
even though i'm getting this money my
life would never change and then i got
songs explaining
how [ __ ] just trying to use me and i
understand you feel me like it's
it's a lot of when you listen to myself
understand this from my real place and
it happened and i wanted to be like oh
this [ __ ] is crazy i feel the same way
like i want more relatable music how old
were you when you got locked up
i was 16 15. oh [ __ ] yeah i was 15 years
old
um well my first time i was i was 13 and
i
i got did a little couple months in like
some little boot camp [ __ ] it wasn't
crazy
and then uh i got locked up like 16 or
15 until i was like 16 and a half
and then after that i said never again
how long were you in yeah
oh [ __ ] what was it for remember the
head button teacher
yeah you heard by the teacher yeah i
don't know if you seen
the [ __ ] uh breakfast club [ __ ]
that was the headline morehead
teacher so you headbutted i didn't i
didn't he was an intervention specialist
so they hit you
with an aggravated assault yeah and what
what they do is they
the job they have is to grab the kids
slam them and let them know who the boss
and i felt like he was trying to be do
too much i'm older now i understand bro
you
you're doing your job so i appreciate
you but at the time i was a knucklehead
and i didn't i didn't like that [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of my face what were you
doing that where they had to
intervene no cat i wasn't doing [ __ ]
like i was trying to write my girl a
little love that i got doing my work on
time so i'm gonna computer [ __ ]
right hello
he was like did you actually use the
computer i'm like yo bro i already got
it okay with the teacher like you know
i'm going to teach you my [ __ ] relax
let's go in the hallway where your job
is
gillette and i'm in my business he i
printed out get ready to fold it up i
write draw him her name on it my hearts
he take my [ __ ] rip it and throw it in
the trash and like i said you have no
permission dude i'm like yo bro chill
the [ __ ] out just ask this [ __ ] if i
could do it he said yeah
you know how i am chill out bro i'm
trying to have a good [ __ ] day ma i'm
already got mashing on my brain and i'm
dealing with real [ __ ] life in this
school get the [ __ ] out of my face you
feel me like
and i don't think he understood where i
was coming from like i'm a kid you was
doing a lot
of [ __ ] at home at the time a lot of
[ __ ] at home a lot of [ __ ] in the street
last year my
my family got sure but myself it's like
bro get the [ __ ] out of here like i'm
really
i'm in the school for a reason because i
i'm i'm trying to get out the [ __ ] you
feel me
[ __ ] didn't understand i wrote it again
he grabbed the paper again and ripped it
i'm like yo bro i'm about to steal you
like you really pissing me off
he went in my face when to grab me first
thing i [ __ ] it
let me there we there now
was he bleeding i don't know after that
[ __ ] jumped on me okay so i don't know
what happened today i didn't know i was
gonna flow it was like five [ __ ] on me
so was it sophomore year
yeah 10th grade yep hell yeah um i was
on the ground
like 20 minutes later police came out
behind the cop car and
was down yeah probably all that [ __ ]
so you end up in jail juvie's uh julie
yeah obviously um damn so you got your
ged in juventus
yeah my dumb ass thought i could get my
ged and go back to high school i don't
know why i thought that [ __ ]
i got okay i was like bro you already
graduated a little bit i was like
it's over now that's my gd show today
i'm doing well i can get out then go to
high school play football
and get my i got out like what the [ __ ]
happened
[ __ ] i'm 16 i'm out of school i don't
know what the [ __ ] to do with my life
what were you doing like you get out of
jail 16 done with high school all your
friends are probably still in school
you've been gone a year and a half like
what did you end up doing with your free
time
uh uh that that's when the time god
gotta get a little shifty you feel me
like when you start chilling with [ __ ]
who's not in school now you start
chilling with them [ __ ] you have to
chill because nobody's around but older
[ __ ]
they start trying to be involved and
follow really deep into their ways
because that's all you know now
all my homies that i would probably
chill with and if we fight and we do
dumb [ __ ] that's cool
we be kids right but the older [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] around like that like you
feel me
you get into some real [ __ ] and like
thank y'all [ __ ] for the lessons but i
[ __ ] wish i never learned them
lessons so you was around some like
that's like you kind of got out of jail
and then the circle you started to keep
was
definitely not the same circle that you
would before you would win because all
your friends are probably going to
school
yeah [ __ ] just football doing doing a
thing so like but
i've always tried to keep a a another
circle
if you mean like every hood [ __ ] if
you're really in the street like that
you got to have some [ __ ] who not me
so when you explain your [ __ ] out loud
to these [ __ ] who don't understand it
it sounds dumb as [ __ ]
yo this [ __ ] said these [ __ ] talking
crazy i'm about to pull up and do that
they're like what the [ __ ]
right you know to keep you grounded you
know the guy he beeping with nah
so why you gotta go do it cause he said
so
oh damn now you're like what the [ __ ]
hell no what the [ __ ] going you need you
need homies to be like yo that i don't
that [ __ ] don't make sense to me you
mean i think i always kept those
so when i finally went back to favor and
i had to understand who i was and find
myself i had my kid i'm like yo i
i don't want to be that following ass
[ __ ] who really got to sit back and
like that decision was dumb and [ __ ]
cause i followed another [ __ ]
that's whack yeah that's why it's
important for you to say man because
some people
i feel like we're up because you're
you're not as young as a lot of your
peers
yeah because we look at you as a new
artist yeah but you've been making music
for a long time
oh yeah and and you're not like you're
not 19. i'm not going to ask you how old
you are but you're not 19. should i tell
you i'm 28. you're 28. you're a grown
ass
man yeah you're a grown-ass man
but like you know a lot of the peers
that you're coming up with
you know i feel like there's a lot of
that energy where
it's just a lot of [ __ ] going on
where you see
people getting cases and yeah this
internet beef [ __ ] is crazy
around yeah it's what you look no cap
every [ __ ] that's over the age of 28
i've liked myself too
you we responsible for the [ __ ] behind
us you got you gotta think about that
[ __ ] they only doing what the [ __ ] or
adapting to what the [ __ ]
was already doing right you know what i
mean little [ __ ] like oh this [ __ ]
get hold of this money that would never
happen to me
i'ma blast that [ __ ] first we put him
on to that mentality you feel me so like
now it's time for us to reverse that
[ __ ] bring that [ __ ] the [ __ ] back to
where it's supposed to be
i'm not saying i'm a martyr or none of
that [ __ ] but if i got little homies
and they're making dumb decisions i
don't give a [ __ ] around you that's just
stupid as hell but [ __ ] relax
that's crazy think first make a smart
decision if you want to get a [ __ ] back
why do it loudly
yo i'm telling you at least shut the
[ __ ] up some of this rap beef [ __ ] going
on right now
is the most wildest [ __ ] i've ever seen
like these jacksonville boys
are [ __ ] insane
young and they shot the video on the
golf course and then
the other cat shot the video on the
grave of the dude who
is dead i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on out here like this [ __ ] it's crazy
all i'm gonna say is
i wish all y'all [ __ ] safe travels in
your life
be careful if you really gonna if you
really do this [ __ ]
and you really like that at least pray
every day so your soul is contained
a lot of [ __ ] i understand you can't
get out of that that's who the [ __ ] you
are right
right right but brother pray trust
yourself
and if you can't trust your [ __ ]
please get new [ __ ] you can trust
cause
[ __ ] is crazy out here but to everybody
out there doing that [ __ ] hey please
stay safe
when i first met you you were with wifey
yeah she was in the studio with you
sir how long have you guys been together
uh seven years but we've been married
three
and and you when did you have your first
baby like
in life 19 2011. he said 19 2000. no i
was 19.
okay okay okay oh god so different baby
mama yes
different bit how many kids you got
three three yeah yeah how many with the
wife
uh one one okay the first one was my
first wife oh okay
oh so you you're double married no cat
so you've been married divorced and
remarried
i found the love baby no cat i respected
it i did what it is
oh god [ __ ] no [ __ ] oh my god you
can talk about it all like look this is
how you make the marriage work this is
where you don't [ __ ] up okay
that's what i want to do for all my
[ __ ] out here who [ __ ] all these
hoes all these females
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] i'm telling you if
you [ __ ] one [ __ ] the right way one
girl the right way your ass gonna be lit
[ __ ] you ain't gonna worry about [ __ ]
you feel me every i think these [ __ ]
out here and these females are so
entwined and trying to be what what what
the media and what [ __ ] music
is showing you
know find out who you are yourself
mm-hmm like music is supposed to help
you out but it's not probably make you a
different [ __ ] person like
people take the music and run with that
[ __ ] like you listen to this [ __ ] and
he had killers so now you were killer
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] and this girl
you're a good girl she's a thought that
you would thought like what the [ __ ] is
happening like
you don't got to follow along i think a
lot of people live their life
for other people yes yes they do they
live their life
for um
for whatever they give a [ __ ] about what
other people think before they care
about what makes them happy
exactly that's the wrong move facts bro
the wrong move
so you're why like like you've been
together with your wife for seven years
uh what what's some advice you give to
you know people to kind of have a
successful relationship because that's a
long time to be with anybody bro
no cap it's it's it's hard and that's
the first thing i want
everybody who's looking for love to
understand it's hard as [ __ ]
yeah you don't get nobody in this easier
it gets harder so you guys understand
how to [ __ ] to deal with each other
we lived together before we got married
so we knew exactly what we were getting
into right people don't even want to go
through the journey
but they're so quick to fall in love you
don't even know the [ __ ] you
with but you love them you post them on
your instagram your social
media y'all know each other's passwords
or you knew each other for two months
what's crazy [ __ ] is happening that's
crazy like what happened to the talking
phase
yeah that's crazy no i'm a [ __ ] no i
love [ __ ] like the next [ __ ] don't get
me wrong you feel me
but what i said what happened to the
talking stage right
no full disclosure every hood [ __ ] you
might laugh me after this my wife didn't
let me [ __ ] for three months 90 days
no [ __ ] and i stuck around took on
dates rubbed that [ __ ] feet
showed up we ate dinner together no we
didn't
hey i did the same thing with my wife
bro it's fire i'ma keep it a band like
[ __ ] it sounds crazy but when you wait
and then she give it to you and it's
crazy you'll be like oh
i think i love a little bit yeah i'm
gonna stay a little longer and he
already been three months so that's what
those two is in that three months you
guys [ __ ] with each other for
everything else besides the sex besides
and then if the sex is fired that means
like oh [ __ ] you got a homie and you've
been
married now yeah bro it worked out so
well we watched movies together [ __ ]
smoke weed now we watch my [ __ ]
dog bro she be on the road with you and
[ __ ] moving
around with you the only time she stay
home though cause when we like all right
look we've been with my kids with two
kids too long
somebody has to be there to let them
know that they're still our kids
right right right right right and that's
the only time if that's not the case she
with me
no [ __ ] tell me about fayetteville
because it's uh
i mean we all know j cole's from
fayetteville right and i've seen uh
when cole did his documentary where he
went back home and performed there was
like a
kind of a behind the scenes look at the
city and it just seems like a very it's
a small town
yes right like it seems like if you
don't have something going on there it's
probably very easy to get wrapped up
into some [ __ ] because there ain't
nothing going on there's nothing going
on
so yeah like what was it like growing up
there and kind of give us a rundown of
your town bro
fayetteville is is is the most prettiest
ugliest beautiful nastiest place in the
world
and and shout out to catwoman because
i'm saying that [ __ ] first you feel me
i feel like that's the best example
because there's so much nice [ __ ] and so
much [ __ ] as well right
but i feel like as far as being who you
want to be i love my city because [ __ ]
is who they are
if a nigga's a gangster he's a gangster
if he a broke bum ass [ __ ] broke my
mask [ __ ] if you're a fly [ __ ] and get
[ __ ] [ __ ] you get [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
just
they be who they are and nobody has
shame in that game in my city that's why
i love that [ __ ] like
i found out who i am in that city
because that city let me be who i
am was like i can imagine is
you know having someone who's one of the
top
three rappers on the planet come from
your city
like you know cole's an
icon you know uh he's a legend he's
you know i always say there's the uh the
mount rushmore of hip-hop and three of
those slots
have been the same for like 10 years and
straight cole and kendrick
like how much of an inspiration was cole
growing up because like again like if
you're in the streets you might not be
listening to cole
you know i know because like you know
nicole's on some lyrical [ __ ] but like
man you can't help but probably be
inspired by that dude coming out of your
town right no no cap
the the first song that i i heard from j
cole
was who that of course yeah and and when
when you were in fayetteville he tried
to video in favor that [ __ ] went
like oh [ __ ] fever lit now like no cat
that he's the martyr for the video like
[ __ ] you the only [ __ ] come out excuse
me
but you only need to come out bro we
look at him like yo i want to be that
so for him to to really put that
footprint on my city and
him to say my [ __ ] is amazing i'm behind
him bro that [ __ ]
my big bro lit and i'm a little bro now
so i'm hey i'm cool with that you feel
me
yeah i mean i mean there has to be a
there has to be
the j cole murray song
bro i know you know he's tapped in if he
hit no look
we we talk he's a solid [ __ ] but if he
ever say more hop on this track i
promise you
i'm gonna fly away from that
[ __ ] and i'm hopping on the song
and personally [ __ ]
you know they did that with the last
dreamville project they just flew
everybody in like right that was the
most random
like like assortment of artists on one
pro like yeah you got that's got to be
that's
that's got to be that's going to happen
i hope so debut album you got to get the
culvers
on your album my mixtape is out so no no
your mixtape's out but i'm saying
album we're calling it a mixtape so that
means the album's coming yeah hell yeah
j cole you see me hey follow my boy oh
god
i [ __ ] with it oh god i'll fold it up
too hard the baby too
hey enough kind of stand the [ __ ] up how
hard is it uh
being a father while you're on the road
and while you're kind of also
being one of the hottest new artists on
the planet right now
it's getting harder because like now
when i leave
i feel my kids be like all right daddy i
thought you weren't gonna you feel me
like so now i gotta have that
conversation like that you gotta go do
this so i can
and that conversation to my baby is
trying to get a little old already you
know what i mean
they're kids so all they care about is
me being there so it does get a little
harder but that's why after like every
interview i try to facetime or text my
wife like they have anything good
if they make sure everybody's straight
but they they still want their daddy so
i'm still learning because i'm still new
but and the touring hasn't even started
yet yeah that's what i'm saying
and that's coming they already know
about me leaving touring them even worse
so i'm gonna figure out if i got
tortured in the summer i'm about to
bring my own [ __ ] rv i had them in
the back and we got to ride together
[ __ ] it how do your kids uh nine eight
and four
oh yeah you got the squad okay and they
understand [ __ ] now so i gotta oh yeah
especially the nine and the eight
yeah they're hip to their [ __ ] oh god i
got two boys so i
really gotta show them that a man is
more than just his job more just his
career that he he's a family person too
so how long were you making music
because i kind of had this conversation
with you like you've been making music
for a minute yeah we're real um
what like like were you always doing the
melodic [ __ ] or like did you kind of
grow into that like because like and
then kind of give me kind of like a
background on like how long you've been
making [ __ ] like uh
i started with the melodic [ __ ] okay
that's how you started because
of listening to drake the the so far
so-called album
of course really made me realize i could
do both like i didn't even know i could
rap
until i got a little older and then i
then i was like [ __ ] do hip-hop like
just
boom back rap right just try that out
and i was like it ain't hitting because
i don't even know what the [ __ ] is going
on i'm not putting i'm just trying to
rap
[ __ ] rapping like no cap um rest in
peace fred the god like
the god says oh god listen to freddie
god i was trying to wrap like him feel
me like he had some bars
what yeah friends [ __ ] soaking money
you know i'm telling you to keep
[ __ ] suck money your [ __ ] once
didn't repeat it these [ __ ] talking
you [ __ ] i'm all the stomach mosquito
like i love hot so i love how he rap
that [ __ ] so smooth and i wanted to do
that but i couldn't
get it you feel me i was like what the
[ __ ] is happening i kept choosing
singing and rapping
2021 until 21. 2
000 and i'm gonna say 14
and when i really realized like no cap
i'ma do this [ __ ] for real i call my
homeboy my
come home away like yo neil i know you
engineer i don't know how good you are
and give a [ __ ] how good you are
can you bring your equipment to my crib
let's record this song
and see what happens and then my wife
loved the song she was like yo i
that's fighting it was it was the first
time before quicksand that i said some
real [ __ ]
and after that it was nothing but
[ __ ] wow and i was like i couldn't
find that anymore i'm like one song and
i put on soundcloud it got love and i'm
like yo
i can't make nothing else like now it's
just i'm going back to the [ __ ]
i don't know just talking to street [ __ ]
yeah like it was just like yeah regular
that was like
it was fine though but it was like i
think like
what's dope about your [ __ ] is like it's
you know you can kind of relate to your
if you're going through the struggle if
you're [ __ ] your [ __ ] is real
relatable you know what i'm saying
and you could you could feel it in your
voice you know i mean like the pain you
know what i mean like
um so you you had had a journey in music
for a while
uh what ended up catching mo's attention
quick saying like when my wife had a
conversation to tell me like yo
write some [ __ ] that you're gonna be
proud of like write some [ __ ] that when
you hear me like yo i did this
i took that [ __ ] as a personal challenge
i took our last blunt
she was hot though i don't give a [ __ ] i
think i last went in the bathroom and
like secluded myself for like three
hours and just like took my time
listening to the beats and writing the
songs
made a video of my homeboy he hit my
homeboy like yo
i want to [ __ ] with him at home we're
like yo some some dude from kelly like
he wanna sign i'm like hey i know i know
the [ __ ] you don't like this is fake as
hell but
give my number see what happens my wife
answered the phone
he was like yo i [ __ ] with you i want to
push your songs to the top and i'm like
hell yeah
he was like you ain't gonna be rich fast
and give you all this money but you
gonna work hard i was like what the
you knew marshmallow was yeah of course
no cat my kids know marshmallow of
course they did they loved it they
probably wanted to be in for halloween
oh god
my son said this he was like dad i seen
you in the picture with marshmallow that
your thousand
ain't my damn cousin cousin [ __ ] they
say
so so that the video was already out
yeah
yeah damn and then from there it was
just it was over yeah no cat
like he he he did exactly what he said
he's gonna do he said
if i worked he's gonna work with me and
we're working together and [ __ ] has been
popping how many records are you sitting
on right now
probably like a hundred and five
hundred and six 105 songs i believe so
yeah yeah no cat
no no i made seven while i was here so
112
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah no count well you
gotta [ __ ] put the album together
how that you gotta go through that was
the hard part for street sermons like
figuring out like okay we got a hundred
of these things
like what to do with them like which
ones are making the cut yeah like it was
i feel like it was
it's so dope because street sermon has
so many
fire ass songs but it's so dope that i
have
not even sound like i'm talking [ __ ] but
i have a lot of other songs i could have
chose
right that would have still fit the same
vibe because i'm always being me
and then i also have songs that when
people hear them they're gonna be like
what the [ __ ]
i want them to do that i want you to
know exactly who i am
so i can't hear you so i can never give
you the same [ __ ] again i promise you
that
please do not expect for more to keep
you sad i want to take you through a
variety of emotions
i want to give you a variety of
different things i want to tap into
different genres i want people to look
at me and follow my journey like yo
we went everywhere with moire it wasn't
just hip-hop it wasn't just
r b it's country edm whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] want me
i want to i want to show up you don't
want to show up you got some country
[ __ ] in the car
oh no not yet hey anybody want to shout
who country hey you won't
[ __ ] with me oh god i want [ __ ] say
they want to smoke
but all these [ __ ] [ __ ] a joke oh god
yo who uh obviously outside of cole um
who's somebody who
tapped in that was a fan of of you that
you were kind of like surprised by where
you were like oh [ __ ] i grew up like
this is this is crazy
this person even knows who i am jay-z oh
no [ __ ] cole i love you my boy
boy [ __ ] jay-z put me on his lip
i said hold up hold on hold on i said
this [ __ ] can't be real like this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] crazy
27 i don't care nobody said number may
not mean nothing to nobody but that
number means some [ __ ] to me
27 on this playlist i wasn't even born
when you was rapping probably
you feel me right [ __ ] and you came out
with your clouds
to come back to earth amongst regular
people would say when you find out you
were on his it was the end of the year
playlist right
obviously yeah what was that like what
like that's
huge i forgot who i didn't even see it
at first somebody told me
like real [ __ ] i think would either it
would be the mo or my homework gutter
like that was like yo
chase either nothing nah that's [ __ ]
that's cat that's
that's not cat oh wow yo yo yo that's
not cap hey baby that's not [ __ ] cat
brow was in that [ __ ] that's
more like 14 blunts bro
dude i was happy as hell no cat that's
big man
did you have any communication with hope
after that or nah not not
personally no i ain't talk to no cap
[ __ ] i don't even know about it what
about somebody you've actually like hung
out with
like you know whether it's in the studio
or you've just met that's like
you were like yo that's crazy like this
person is is
[ __ ] with my music or somebody who
you met who was like dope no
cap i ran into uh i ran into herbo my
first time
my second time in um in the [ __ ] la
and that [ __ ] was five like i didn't
know a lot
dude man i [ __ ] with boyle i was like
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] in the studio and
then right after him
you got other [ __ ] uh who was popped up
killer roy was walking past through them
oh [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] you're just
walking through the studio this [ __ ]
crazy sitting and seeing corey in the
studio
i'm just in my is incredible bro he's a
that [ __ ] got this also i think he's
got roots
in fayetteville and raleigh hell yeah
right yeah and raleigh they're doing
rally yeah
north carolina yeah he's got roots in
carolina north carolina is going crazy
bro
telly whole state i'm telling you going
stupid bro
hey it was so dope when the baby and
cole hopped on a record together
uh at the beginning of uh the revenge of
the dreamers [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
huge that's all five [ __ ] two how far is
charlotte from fayetteville two hours
and 35 minutes
like y'all like i mean it's like is it
like a
is it because like you said north
carolina is kind of in there
in his bag right now the whole state
yeah it's going crazy
yeah like the babies but charlotte is
going down
charles is going stupid right now it's
it's it's impressive for sure
uh i want to say the first thing i
noticed when i watched the video was
how amazing the song was but i knew
how important it was for everyone who's
got a sweating problem
to see you with that sweat rag bro hey
look look cook's got his sweat rag right
there
every fat [ __ ] got a sweat rag no
[ __ ] even if you ain't got in your
pocket in your car or something to dab
that forehead stop playing the games
i know you got it oh god how much love
did you get for the sweat rag
a lot no come off by making some [ __ ] no
[ __ ] yo y'all gotta that's gotta be
the merch bruh
i gotta be part of my birthday that's
like a fat [ __ ] i was like oh this guy
got the
the lrg and the sweat rag he's going up
and i was using that [ __ ] too yeah he
was he was patting himself
oh god i was sweating like a
[ __ ] it was like a [ __ ] 94
degree out hottest sailboat i was like
look at this guy with the sweat rack
for the big homies bad boy [ __ ] always
yo have to stop the bootleg head podcast
real quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the drawls man the
boxer briefs are so
fire they're so soft they feel great on
your ass
your nuts whatever you're into you know
what i'm saying whatever you got they'll
cover them up real real comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know
one of the licenses they just got that i
love uh are the naruto socks they just
got the naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks thank me later save 20
off at checkout by using the keyword
bootleg kev at oddssocksoficial.com
and we are super proud that they're
presenting this podcast
let's get back to it so um this the last
time i saw you didn't have any jewelry
on you got the you got the [ __ ] grill
you got the watches
how how recent did you get this watch
all this [ __ ] is new
um i'm getting my man emotional easy bro
just saying he's proud of me
what kind of watch is that uh she's got
a rolex ap
oh it's an ap
it seems it seems to be kind of uh gaudy
for your nature
who i would say like like it feel weird
does it feel weird to be walking around
with someone's like like you know
bentley on your wrist this has been i
don't know i don't know honestly no nick
it was a great how much is the watch
tony
50k that's that's a like a it's a great
kia minivan like fully loaded
50k man oh you know they got it's a nice
watch
wait you got that that was gifted to you
yes i'm saying like all this [ __ ] like
no cam
like mo no that's not me right so he
like yo bro just
i'll get it for you then [ __ ] it you
flex one time but i ain't a [ __ ]
i'm a big relaxer fifty thousand hey
[ __ ] coming hey worst comes the worst
sell that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying oh god where's
she hits the [ __ ] you said that number i
said i wonder how much i can get for no
[ __ ]
oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] like that i gotta
fight marie ward
oh [ __ ] um what is going to be the
difference between the mixtape and the
album
for you the mixtape is more of who who
mo
morey is or who more he was the album
gonna be is who morey
want to be who he's gonna be who already
striving to be
and i think that's gonna go crazy like
only because i'm thinking of
possibilities of what could be
you feel me like i'm new in this game
i'm like a newborn [ __ ] baby and i
love that [ __ ] cause everything is
wonderous i love
all of this [ __ ] like what [ __ ] think
i would be upset about doing some [ __ ]
i'm like
yeah yeah hold on what's going on [ __ ]
it let's do this in my boy here hit me
on god like
[ __ ] it hey also too you were grinding
for so many years like
i can only imagine like to finally make
it it's got to be like
damn cause i because i i mean look
you're 28 i'm sure that there were some
times where you was making music or you
thought about not doing this [ __ ] no
more just just just
doing the regular job [ __ ] bro no i i
quit
half of my career doing music
because i feel like either i wasn't good
enough
there's 20 [ __ ] out here who trying to
do this [ __ ] in my city i was never
going to be
seen i didn't have enough money for the
studio time
i don't know how to buy these [ __ ]
beats from these youtube [ __ ]
there was so much [ __ ] going on i was
like yo this is i would lose my no cat
bro
i had a whole album and i lost my phone
i lost like 40 songs damn
right before quicksand like no cap i
quit like
three months before quicksand i lost my
whole phone i got a new phone
[ __ ] that was the only place you had
these songs you have a [ __ ] hard
drive a lot none of that
i ain't never handling that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] i had a [ __ ] android no [ __ ]
and i lost my [ __ ] at work
hey i got both but i still got my
android oh god okay i got an iphone now
i got i got both but you know
i can't can't let go of the galaxy you
know yeah yes you can
he said yeah you can i did it
yo um did you find the quicksand beat on
youtube
hell yeah no you just found the beat on
youtube what what did you type in on
youtube like what type beats did you
type in to find it because everyone
types in like
something type beat no ca i put um what
i put smoove hip hop and r b and it
popped up
it popped up i was like what the [ __ ]
and there was a um
it was a type b oh [ __ ] was it
a roddy type beat roddy rich type beat
it really was rodney richardson like
somebody else
right x somebody else or what it was i
said [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] when i was
yourself like it's your heart
i'm like let me see if i can do my [ __ ]
on a [ __ ] and then it just it
just
i already because i have wrote some of
the lyrics without the beat right right
i was i was in my feelings i was just
writing and i was like this beat sonic
go crazy
okay kept writing i was like
no cat i'ma use this beat i download
that [ __ ] you two mp3 [ __ ] somebody
what do you do
it exists is that there and i got that
beat use that [ __ ]
hit him up like bro i want to buy the
beat did you buy the beat before
it was like huge yeah yeah how much was
the beat original i have no idea
but it probably went a lot i don't think
so by a couple hundred dollars or
something maybe
i don't know a lot of those youtube type
beats i mean you could lease them mm-hmm
hey this song probably changed that
guy's life too hey i think his name was
um
aunt chamblin yeah look him up bro he
got some [ __ ] [ __ ]
real rap hey that youtube [ __ ] is real
nope it's some fire youtube producers
[ __ ] they actually no cat hey so you
you mentioned you actually still write
your lyrics down because a lot of times
like almost everybody i've been in the
studio with over the last like five or
six years
they like hum the melody right and then
they kind of fill in the lyrics as they
go are you still like
actually writing lyrics which i think is
super dope i'll show you my phone tom
stamp no [ __ ]
i wrote yesterday no but like i write my
phone and my process is so weird when i
show you how i write you're not gonna
make no sense
especially because you're like a melodic
guy so do the lyrics come first or the
melody
or or is it it's it depends on the beat
like look how right it don't make no
sense
it just you feel me spaces and slashes
you feel me just yeah
but it makes sense you know what's crazy
with the slashes is back in the day
do you remember in uh in the source they
used to do the hip hop quotables yeah
they used to have slashes in between the
bars
that's how my dad used to write like he
rapped too oh your dad was a rapper that
was rapping back in the day so when he
write actually look at his book and he
used to have a little slashers
that affect come think that's pretty
wild right
because you're pops that's crazy as [ __ ]
did your dad have any sort of like
success locally or was he just kind of
like i don't know what boy
but i know they said something i don't
know i don't know about this no
you you got a good relationship with
your partner he cool
yeah cool yo hit boy uh you know who hit
boy is
hell yeah yeah hip boy uh his dad got
out of jail and and they did like a
uh hs 87 album and his dad was rapping
all over the album and this [ __ ] came
out fire as [ __ ]
i believe we did we you guys aren't
there yet we
we ain't there nah he said nah rapping
under my [ __ ]
can't have none of this boy keep doing
your thing be safe but
no features on street sermons no sure um
i really wanted to be
like my [ __ ] i want people to like
like me for me like you don't bring your
homie on a date do you
no [ __ ] stay your ass with your crib
let me get on this first date let me
let's get to know me let me grab a hand
get a little kiss first
right second date she bring her homie we
lit you feel me
that's how i wanted to be this is a
relationship trying to build my fans
i want them to know that i'm gonna give
them everything that i can no cap and i
want
also my colleagues to know an industry
like yo he gonna come with some [ __ ]
if you want me a song i'm not gonna
[ __ ] your song it'd also be so easy
for you to like it be like so typical
like with who your manager is and [ __ ]
like for you to like come with some
crazy
i think it's like dope that you're doing
that because like you said you're
building a relationship with your fans
it's not based on who's on your [ __ ]
yeah honestly i think i think i owe it
to them anyways like
i oh [ __ ] um really got a lot of
questions so i really want them to
understand like
i'm gonna give y'all me so there's no
doubt who the [ __ ] i am
facts i'm a genuine cool [ __ ] that's it
is there gonna be a quicksand remix not
ever
ever i'm so sorry that hey that's dope
that's my baby
i listen to that song and know like yo
when i put that song out i was so damn
bad i didn't bro i didn't know where
i was going to live you feel me it's
like what the [ __ ] is happening right
now i got to pay my rent to do next
month my car
overdue cardinal is [ __ ] two months
i'll do actually like
cell phone off three kids i got a wife
that song saved my life motion leagues
he picked six
saved my life i would never i would
never remix it i would never
do nothing okay since we know that there
isn't a remix yeah and it's never gonna
happen
never gunned your head hypothetically
speaking
who would you have put on the remix if
that if in a different world if a remix
would actually happen
if you could have your choice to for
your baby who would you have put on it
now we know it's never going to happen
but who would if you had to
i would say two who the first one i
would say i would say cole because he
for my city
second one i think rowdy will provide
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
for sure he would have [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up no count like for sure out too how
uh now's the time of year where the
double xl freshman thing is starting to
become a discussion a discussion you
were
nominated um thank you they nominated
you
uh crazy how important would that be for
you to make that cover
it'll be hella important like i that's
like no cap the hood really
really [ __ ] with double xl as far as
like
notability in the hood like double excel
yeah that changes your life you feel me
like and i've always grew up watching
them [ __ ]
like one of my favorite ones the one
with the baby like that [ __ ] rap
for like [ __ ] three minutes four
minutes yeah took over the show
like i i like [ __ ] megan stallion body
that [ __ ] too
[ __ ] was gone that's all [ __ ] crazy
that's what i wanted i want to i want to
make a step in the world
and double xl will help me make my first
stance so if you make the cover
how are you going to do your freestyle
are you going to like come with some
bars or are you gonna do
the straight melody [ __ ] are you gonna
do a little bit of both because you
could rap rap too
you could do both okay i mean when it
comes to freestyling
you you really gotta fill that beat up
if it means so like depends on what beat
if yeah i mean yeah if you make it of
course oh god but if
i made the double xl no cap depending on
what beat they put on i really want to
just let [ __ ] know that
i can go hypothetically speaking you get
on the cover who do you think
deserves to be on the cover with you uh
42 doug facts i think he should be able
this sheisty
fax um let me see
i don't know a lot of damn i'm so sorry
i'm blanking right now
i mean those two i think are probably
shoo-ins yeah yeah
they too lit they they too legit they
quit looking at five yeah i'm like yo if
those guys don't make it i don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing
let me i'm trying to see i it was a lot
of people up there that i was like hell
yeah they definitely gotta make it
uh coyla rae is probably gonna make it
mm-hmm hell yeah yeah she's
i think she's on there yeah yeah i
believe so i hope have you tapped in
with blast yet
from l.a i have it oh man ain't
happening with him yet
matter of fact yeah he fired he's fired
yeah you guys
make some [ __ ] i think so i think so yo
you in blast i think so bro
crazy oh god oh my what
yeah he's he's crazy um so
street sermons is out what if if
someone's watching this and they've
already heard quicksand but they're like
they really haven't dived into the stuff
you've been putting out since then
what's the one song
you want everyone to go to first on the
project uh i like if they can only hear
one song on the project
mistakes mistakes that's the first song
you will hear my project
that's the intro yes sir i love that
song because
it's really gonna stay who i am like
you're gonna listen to this i'm like
okay yeah i can see that [ __ ] like i
could see
what he trying to do i could see who he
is i could see the man trying to become
and that's my baby i love that song
mistake on the new record you
said the word jabroni on it yeah uh that
made me think that you may or may not be
a wrestling fan
no cap i used to [ __ ] with wwe no
[ __ ] like the rock is the man
you know people eyebrow got that stone
cold stunning on god
god i said available seen the good
spirit a couple times so you used to be
in your spare time like what is it like
if if we're at your crib or like
what are your hobbies what are your
interests are you into sports are you
into gaming like what are you yeah i
know
i play 2k no no [ __ ] madden or you
know gta type [ __ ] like
i'll be chilling like i'm a dad so i
already do the whole party this year so
like
smoking weed and two of my homies and
playing games really what's the go-to
team on 2k this year
clippers really always the clippers
always
would you consider yourself a clipper
fan of course why that's my squad
has it always been your squad baron
davis oh b diddy okay so you og with it
okay he played for the hornets
of course and me being from fayetteville
he was the guy when he was with the
hornets so i [ __ ] with him and i just
follow him to all his squads
but i was not following him to the next
yeah because that was wash be ditty i'm
not following you to the next bro the
clip was the way i'm staying
[ __ ] with the clippers yeah no
captain and now they're we got it [ __ ]
[ __ ] what every time i don't care
i'll [ __ ] with y'all let's get it they
got rajon rondo now okay we got we got
we got beat demarcus cousins at the
bottom
demarcus cousins he ain't been boogie
for a while he bought the bee
you hot show hey boogie [ __ ] stop
playing with my wife so you're not a
hornets fan
nah i gotta love them nobody's two and a
half
i mean i'm not essentially a north
carolina sports team fan like i even
like i like seahawks
man you're a seahawks fan sarnia alex
alexander 2008 maddox sean alexander
every single [ __ ] game and i've been
a fan of them since he played with him
so
i follow i follow a player then once he
goes i just stay with the squad
wow so no [ __ ] like not walking with the
panthers i mean keep pounding but pound
out ass over there because the seahawks
coming through baby [ __ ] time
oh god
yo russell wilson man i thought they
were going to trade him headed but
not maybe you know there's no cattle
seahawks listen i'm a fan but if y'all
trade russell i'm going to wrestle
you're going where he's going don't play
this game with me please don't play this
game i don't give a [ __ ] i look out of
debt but if russell leave
i'm going with russell on the game
that's hillary hey what's the most
random [ __ ] that that if someone were to
check your
playlist that you're listening to that
would that would be like surprise like
oh this [ __ ] is listening to
this uh
you will probably find diedrich hadn't
sung god is good that's my [ __ ] i play
like it's a trap song
i don't even know what that is god is
good god is
good oh that's so there's no nickelback
on your
this playlist he's the only one that
makes me laugh that's how far
[ __ ] with them boys yo have you ever
been in a white strip club and they
played nickelback
hell yeah it's funny no honestly
nickelback gives these girls and they
back they
all trying to be so dumb they go to that
white strip club and they throw in that
niggle bag or that creed and you see a
[ __ ] just just
they she dancing she throwing hair she's
just ah it's like what is happening
get me the [ __ ] out of here throw your
neck around you ain't even getting naked
no more you just kept whiplash
yeah you can't dance to that you can't
dance to that [ __ ] but you can find
out what the [ __ ] don't care i watch
mtv six in the morning when i was going
to school with your choice
you you catch you catching vibes blink
182 tight [ __ ] smash mouth you catch
them she says smash mouth you catch him
you catch him
there it is man well look i appreciate
you coming through uh
yeah i mean well we can keep going man i
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] you know i
don't care i [ __ ] with you bro i'll hire
you right now bro i'm
i smoke a lot but i'm high no this vape
pin though this [ __ ] fire
in this wii u you gave me a photo what
you call what
turtle pie turtle pie turtle plot is
[ __ ] no kind of [ __ ]
so like everyone's doing nfts right now
i know your squad is extremely you know
what nfc is yeah
have you heard of nft oh man nft [ __ ] is
crazy put me on
what's mt it's like a [ __ ] you know
what bitcoin is
oh yeah yeah oh my wife go crazy for
crypto
yo your wife's a crypto bro she's a
crypto she's running it up
it's weak no cap i don't know i don't
know who where she get the money from
but she doing her thing no good like
i'll look at you i'm amazing
i'll give me all this money bro like let
me get twitter so your wife is is is
invested in the crypto heavily huh she
she actually you know she's home a lot
and she will meet you with me but she
still be on the couch
she'll be reading her [ __ ] and she
really be she's gonna make me richer
that's my spanker butt
keep going honey have you bought a house
yet i'm looking i'm no guy i got one
logo lord please let me get this house i
i'm trying to close on it now
it's tough right now but the market is
crazy it's insane bro
you're look look the market is crazy
it's crazy i said the market crazy
what the [ __ ] did you have to put a bet
uh a bid in like over the asking price
hell no
because a lot but a lot of these places
we try to buy house you gotta pay like
30 40 over
that's my thing like i look at what the
house
was bought for how many years if it's
progressing
right i'm gonna give you a real [ __ ]
deal like you're not about this here i'm
not about to give you none of that if
you guys are
just gonna buy [ __ ] out cash tell them
about that then
and you're staying near home oh god no
cap
i would never leave no connor i love
north carolina even if i move to raleigh
or
outside the city let's get in the burbs
man just just a house with my family be
comfortable but my compound and my my
heart gonna always been a veal
no cat but i would never leave north
carolina damn yeah that's hey man
you at the real estate is a lot you you
cheat out here you
apartment for the [ __ ] price you get
a [ __ ] mansion where you're ruining
that not to mention every every food i
buy
or uber eats be like eighty dollars out
here oh yeah uber eats
that [ __ ] is correct and fail here
uber eats being your ass out here bro
crazy bro
and the ubers you want to take a [ __ ]
uber out here
bro it cost me like 130 to get from lax
to my house i was like bro that's more
than the flight
but for sure no cat that's crazy [ __ ]
no that's some real [ __ ] you know fly to
vegas for like 50
50 bucks and then you got to take the
uber to lax it's [ __ ] three times the
price that's crazy but in fayetteville
you ain't getting an uber
you might get one there in 45 minutes no
[ __ ] uh
you know obviously shout out to
marshmallow uh you know
he's super nice guy um one of the
biggest superstars in music what's your
guys's relationship like
my goddamn boy i fought one okay what
have you learned from him man because
no cap it's funny because i i sing
of course but he definitely know
pictures and keys and that [ __ ] is so
dope that have somebody in the studio
with so much knowledge and would lend
you the ear
like i feel like [ __ ] take ears for
granted mm-hmm there's
people like him and south side and okay
even mo got a [ __ ] ear right for
music you know what i mean so like when
you got young [ __ ] who who think they
know what they're doing listen to that
[ __ ] that's next to you with that ear
trust me that one thing he might change
may make your song be
far turn it up you feel me and he's a
crazy producer
like bro we always like i think people
who who don't really like tap in with
what he does
melo made it right well but i'm saying
like people like we always like
associate him with like being this big
edm guy like this [ __ ] makes
slappers no
the records he's put out with roddy and
all these people are crazy if he was
black his tag should be
mellow made it right [ __ ] like no cap
it's
it's that hard that he's just to say
mello made it right [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
hard like
do you get like first dibs on some of
his beats
i mean he keep it business you feed me
all the way but that's my boy south side
if i want it i think he'd be like let me
see what's happening you feel me no cat
no cat but we always keep professional
i'm not gonna ask for a beat unless i
know you
don't give it to me okay are you on any
of his com
upcoming music or have you i mean i'm
you guys have had to have collaborated
whether or not it's gonna ever come out
but i mean that would have i mean i mean
i would hope you guys have collaborated
[ __ ] no cat i definitely hop on a couple
of his beats
they fire
together are [ __ ] dangerous you got a
nice little team
of bro i got to rate some of the
greatest producers of all time
squad i got and they they my homies like
right [ __ ] with them [ __ ] bro like we
chill like i [ __ ] with them [ __ ] they
really good people bro
my whole team my [ __ ] tony even they
call them pretty
shout out to waco too ain't that pretty
tony's got uh pretty tony's got [ __ ]
the slim shady thing going on oh god oh
god everybody
got damn boy my [ __ ] nick got it too
but it's brown today yeah
oh god but i got a team like no cut from
from the [ __ ] who take my pictures for
photographer nick from tony to help me
out with
my day to day from schmoe telling me
like yo this is what's happening with
the [ __ ] like
my squad is so fired bro and i [ __ ] with
all of them to the to the end because
they they all [ __ ] with me bro like
i had a discussion with tony nick today
about some [ __ ] i'm like yo i don't feel
like
i should be spending money on this and
because i feel like they're like [ __ ]
if you want a good show
spin that [ __ ] you like your fans say
hello hell yeah i do he was like explain
that [ __ ] how have you give your fans a
good time
and it made me realize like [ __ ] i'm on
a different i'm a different thing now
like i know you guys already talking
about like
like a tour not at all i got a show on
the first and um in rockingham north
carolina
okay and i want to make it open open in
the south yeah it's opened open
wide open nostrils type [ __ ] oh god but
i i want to give a good show wherever i
go i don't give a [ __ ] about the small
venue
how far is that from home uh two hours
and 45 minutes
it's like right next to charlotte's like
right close to them in the same area and
this is like your is this your first
show since the second
second show what was the first one uh i
went to atlanta in the believe hall
um that [ __ ] was dope they were singing
my song and she had the goddamn stage
shaking it was like yeah
yeah i was like what no oh that's still
fine
since you've been making some uh some
good some good rap money uh
what's the dumbest thing you've bought
what's your big purchase so far that you
were like hey man i'ma just do this
i mean the watch was free oh you spend a
lot of money on weed
bro i didn't know i smoked this much
i bought eight jars of weed yesterday
and i'm smoking on just your [ __ ] now do
you blew
through all the hr's huh bro you ca and
and in north carolina it's not legal
hey online that's some truth we still
got the block work
but every house in five block we're done
[ __ ] be like traveling to get the weed
but it's like i
can't wait till we got dispensaries
[ __ ] i love this weed [ __ ] [ __ ]
that especially we different what about
you ever eat edibles yeah don't do that
to me though
edibles don't do nothing to you you know
you're not eating enough not real [ __ ]
uh moe had a bad angle for the name but
it's like a thousand milligrams
like 20 of them and i was like he was
like take one of these before the plane
you only had one
no i ate 16. you made 16 of them they
were gummies
they were i thought it was a snack wait
you didn't do like you didn't do nothing
no
i was hot 16 off the weeds i forgot that
they were
edibles i thought they were just snacks
i'll just eat them [ __ ] like it didn't
kick in
not healing i had to roll like two more
months and then i went to sleep and then
i woke up on time
i don't know what's going on bro have
you ever done mushrooms nah hell or not
i would have
you wouldn't do mushrooms yeah i know
they got hey look i smoke weed my boy
i don't do syrup i don't know listen
don't don't true shrooms is not like
shows is not for me you don't know that
i i do know that [ __ ] yeah
i [ __ ] with that shrimp saying like you
you can't compare it to lean or like
coke
you definitely cannot no but it's
delayed for me on the ga
yeah you got to try that [ __ ] nah nah
you wouldn't try it no
no no that [ __ ] i mean that's good
though wheat is good
you gotta eat more edibles though no
that's for you
or
uh what do you what would you consider
your biggest vice
yeah probably
no prior part of the week i mean if
that's advice oh no
no i'm keeping the ban what the [ __ ]
bites me my my biggest advice
is i like to [ __ ] eat nice plain
bites
like just like i've never heard this
innocent of this crazy advice is like
a con of like like you know some
people's vice is gambling some people's
vice is [ __ ] some people's advices oh
no
some people's vices you know
what would be your biggest vice miyabi
juniors uh
hibachi chicken and steak with rice
zucchini i feel you bro that baby huh
that [ __ ] every no cat when i'm homeless
i
do they have garlic butter at that place
i don't even know on my ass now
listen you get that garlic butter you go
to hey look you go to benny hannah's out
here
same type of setup i just brought by a
tub of garlic butter that's the fancy
place right behind us fancy right it's
not fancy okay it's not any more fancy
than a place you're going to i
bet oh [ __ ] it's a hibachi place where
they cook the food in front of you but
they all they don't say miyabi drinks in
the rap songs yeah because it's [ __ ]
your local joint yeah betty hannas is
like
it's it's like yeah it's i mean it's not
fair it's not it's not any fancier than
[ __ ]
i mean it's a little fancier than that
she expands you to me because you heard
it in rap songs oh god i just started
rapping like i was a fan like six months
ago so let's just still do to me
you gotta get that garlic butter i'm
gonna try i'm gonna draw that i just
don't eat sushi
oh have you ever tried sushi hey that's
gross
dude they got raisin canes in north
carolina oh what raisin canes
hell no what chicken oh man raisin cane
chicken oh my god
we got churches chicken now churches
listen raisin canes you got that cane
sauce boy listen
see you know la got a lot of spice
yeah i love the spices i like to heat
things up
well you know out here there's all kinds
of hot chicken yeah everything
got dave's hot chicken there's all the
hot chicken
firefighter bro i'm saying there's like
dave's hot chicken and then like a
million places that
are fake dave's hot chicks yeah no i
know i want to it's like a [ __ ] hot
chicken place on every corner now
there's a boba a mr boba
boy oh yeah they [ __ ] love both out
here they even have bowman north
carolina
weird as [ __ ] you know do they have wawa
in north carolina no that's
nba why was it you go to that gas
station get you a [ __ ] sandwich what
a sandwich a cheese steak they got fries
all that [ __ ]
get you a [ __ ] full tank of gas of
unleaded going on
three four in the morning get you a
[ __ ] chicken parmesan
sub and a coffee and a coffee
backwoods whatever the [ __ ] you need
whatever you
need is that huawei's how far is
virginia close to you
at four hours okay
have you uh have you done the vegas
thing yet might have been the biggest
oh man when vegas reopens and i'm sure
when mello's got his shows about it yet
you're gonna have fun people like [ __ ]
is
boring i'm like [ __ ] i never been it's
not gonna be boring you've never been to
vegas
brian whenever you go you're gonna do it
like on a level that's like not even
fair
nah i don't bro i'm born as [ __ ]
i hear you but like you're gonna see
vegas at its like highest potential
because it's gonna be fresh because if
you go and like mellow's got like one of
these big club shows
it's gonna be gonna walk through the
back walk through the kitchen or
whatever club
there's gonna be [ __ ] you're gonna
love it it's gonna yeah
but then also like hit like the shitty
downtown casinos
yeah they fire yeah i mean they're
he laughing over there there might be
fire he's he's just don't wear none of
your jewelry
yeah i mean it's like it's called
fremont street it's like oh that's
where you go get a 9.99 steak low
you can just rob the [ __ ] out you no
they won't but it's just it's just like
we're
it's like when you get a 9.99 [ __ ]
the people you see on jerry springer
that's where they got
that [ __ ] they go to fremont street oh
yeah i gotta see that
yeah oh god the ladies that dance to
nickelback
that's where they go talk about some
look at this photograph
no i don't want you anymore don't be a
homeless guy with one leg and a ukulele
covering that for tips on fremont street
one leg and a ukulele oh i'm paying you
something you got to tip them right you
got that's five [ __ ]
i can't play with two legs um
oh god hey yeah that's real uh well look
man
we appreciate you coming through yeah i
appreciate that um the uh
project street sermons is out yes sir
pre-save if you didn't get it well by
the time this comes out it'd already be
out
well it's out go get it please tell me
what you think about it even if you
don't [ __ ] with it i don't even know if
you don't like it
write me let me know what you think have
you already started to kind of like put
songs aside for the official album
of course you always do that so there's
already records that you're like this is
making it no matter what
i got like i got like five or six that i
don't know what that is it's on there
it's on there
was it hard to like uh not put those on
the on this project
hell yeah i bet it was it's like it's so
weird because you
it's so i didn't know it was this nerve
wracking like right it was easy
easy in the street cause you ain't
thinking about that [ __ ] you just
like you just put anything on your
mixtape with your album but when you're
doing it in like
this capacity it's like okay now this
got to go because it's hot
but this going to transcend me is this
what this table is saying or is this
what the album's saying
then it's like it's and it's like [ __ ]
start over because i think right
no this [ __ ] puzzle is impossible but
i'm glad we [ __ ] got it right with
street service no cap y'all gonna love
this [ __ ] we'll go get that [ __ ] and uh
man
thank you for coming through man thank
you for having me i'm gonna come back
and chill with you
let's get it you're rolling with the
wait what are we rolling here we got the
back wood inside of the joint yeah yeah
i always rip half of the back wood
put it in the paper that's some new york
[ __ ] kind of no cat yeah
they was chopping up the [ __ ] grabba
leaf and then sprinkling it in the paper
that [ __ ] that's actually too harsh i
didn't understand it i've never seen
that [ __ ] we're in new york i'm like
what the [ __ ] are y'all doing is that
i thought they were putting angel dust
on their [ __ ] joints
i was like